voilà pour l'effet place à l'analyse
maintenant avec vous Gotty robbinsky
Gauthier est-ce qu'on sait de quel type
d'appareils de quel modèle on parle
lorsqu'on dit qu'il s'agit des attaques
mené au drone alors ça dépend ceux qui
tombent sur Kiev ou ceux qui tombent sur
Moscou sur Moscou non c'est très
difficile on verra bien si la propagande
russe tient à montrer quelques débris de
ces de ces appareils de ses engins parce
que c'est souvent instructif par exemple
vous savez que sur ceux qui savent
s'abattent sur Kief ou sur l'Ukraine
très souvent on arrive à établir la
filiation entre les fameux drones
iraniens 136 et la version améliorée que
Moscou que les Russes produisent bien là
il faudrait pouvoir avoir la même
élément de comparaison et de voir ce qui
s'est abattu sur Moscou dans la dans la
périphérie juste une remarque
effectivement on a vu dans ce récit les
habitants de Kiev qui sont soumis à une
terreur à travers les bombardements
incessants en drôles ce qui serait
intéressant de savoir mais c'est de de
l'illusion ou de l'idéalisme c'est si
les habitants de Moscou qui ont peur et
à juste titre est-ce qu'ils se rendent
compte que c'est en leur nom que ce qui
est perpétré à Kiev et perpétré
parenthèse fini fermé pour pour ces
engins ce qui est important c'est de
voir que si vous voulez ils ont à la
fois un côté pratique si j'ose dire
c'est à dire que il demande pas une
technicité énorme pour les manipuler ils
sont relativement bon marché c'est à
dire que comparé un missile
une un drone iranien coûte entre 25000
et 30000 dollars
nous disait tout à l'heure
c'est très simple voilà c'est pas très
compliqué simplement ça peut le devenir
si après comme les Russes le font je le
disais on bricole la chose mais au
départ c'est très simple et puis
contrairement à ce que j'ai dit dans une
autre édition ça franchit quelque chose
de l'ordre comme 2000 km donc beaucoup
plus si vous voulez que la distance qui
sépare Moscou de Kiev ou
qui pour l'heure et donc accusé en tous
les cas par Moscou d'avoir mené ces
frappes Ukraine adopter une série de
sanctions contre l'Iran pays à l'origine
de la fabrication de de ces drones
oui parce que alors vous avez vu la
séquence récente pour eux pour l'Ukraine
il s'agissait à la fois d'avoir une une
présence sur le terrain russe puisqu'on
a vu qu'il y avait des manœuvres et des
attaques perpétrées par des groupes
russes peut-être mais j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'on les voit un peu trop
souvent ces groupes russes qui auraient
quand même une certaine habilité alors
qu'en fait on sait pas ce sont des
militants pour la plupart d'extrême
droite est-ce qu'ils sont capables de
commettre ce genre de choses comme
peut-être la à Moscou c'est possible
mais on n'en sait rien et j'ai
l'impression qu'on nous sert beaucoup
ces groupes ces groupes de dissidents
russes bref est-ce que le fait d'être en
liaison avec l'Iran pour
l'obtention de ces drones est-ce que ça
fait de Moscou quelqu'un une partie qui
ne sait pas se débrouiller qui n'a pas
la technicité pour répondre aux
Ukrainiens et c'est là si vous voulez
qu'il y a quelque chose d'important
c'est que au fond ce que qui est essaie
de faire c'est de répondre à toutes les
critiques qui veulent que qui est un
petit peu un petit peu trop activiste on
dit vous voyez qu'en Occident on dit ce
qui en fait trop zellens qui avait
promis de ne pas attaquer le territoire
russe sauf avec des armes qui sont les
siennes tout ça si vous voulez c'est une
manière de dire à zelens qui vous
prenait trop de place vous prenez trop
de place et lui qui n'a pas réussi
malgré son voyage spectaculaire en
Arabie Saoudite malgré son voyage
spectaculaire au Japon qui n'a pas
réussi à
glaner des soutiens en quantité
suffisante et bien il y a peut-être
cette manœuvre qui est une manœuvre
finalement diplomatique politique
classique on impose on impose des
sanctions pourquoi faire pour peut-être
essayer de se trouver des amis c'est à
dire des pays qui sans aller jusqu'à
soutenir l'activité militaire de Kiev
disent oui on peut soutenir quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre des sanctions
qui nous engage pas beaucoup on sent le
régime de Kiev et de Janski à la
recherche de soutien parce que justement
dans cette période
ultramiditarisée il n'a peut-être pas
forcément le soutien que lui
appelle de ses vœux on sait que c'est
souvent son son gimmick de répéter qu'il
a besoin de soutien mais que précisément
là il y a quelque chose qui depuis cette
activité en territoire russe qui s'est
un peu grippé entre l'Occident et
malheureusement le problème c'est que
les rues souvent en profiter bien sûr
merci beaucoup Gauthier merci pour cette
an